imaginez voir au travers d'un écran
d'une télé avoir également une télé sans
aucun fil sans aucun câble mais
également des moniteurs gaming en OLED
voici ce qui vient nous présenter LG sur
son stand au CES 2023 des choses
absolument incroyables il y en a qu'on a
déjà vu qui sont un peu recyclés il y a
aussi des vrais nouveautés je suis
vraiment vous emmener en immersion parce
que c'était avec nous sont super cool et
elles vont arriver chez vous vous êtes
prêts pour découvrir les grosses
nouveautés qui ont retenu vont
l'attention sur le stand de LG au CES
1023 on y va
allez-y présente ici une télé qui est
somme toute assez révolutionnaire alors
on connaît on a un très grand écran Oleg
on a une dalle de 97 pouces on connaît
la qualité des dalles LG elles sont
absolument impeccable irréprochable et
ça marche vraiment bien mais là où c'est
extrêmement intéressant c'est que vous
le savez au dos de votre télé vous avez
vos ports pour venir branché au
connectique de l'HDMI de l'USB de
l'optique bref énormément de port qu'on
trouve derrière et ça fait quoi ça fait
que vous avez des câbles qui courent et
les câbles qui courent au bout d'un
moment et bah c'est relou parce qu'il
faut venir les faire passer leur il
existe des systèmes mais c'est pas
parfait et puis derrière ça court
également bref c'est relou Samsung
propose une solution c'est le boîtier
one Connect qui est intéressant
symbolique qui est déporté vous avez un
seul câble qui parle de votre téléviseur
et qui va jusqu'à votre boîtier déporté
donc au lieu d'avoir une multitude de
câbles qui court vous avez un seul câble
mais là où LG va encore plus loin que je
te propose Samsung avec son boîtier one
Connect c'est un boîtier 0 Connect donc
là il faut un petit clin d'oeil
directement à Samsung vous avez one
Connect nous on a zéro Connect ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que vous avez
votre téléviseur avec un seul câble
c'est l'alimentation électrique
forcément sinon ça marchera pas ça sera
un peu compliqué et le reste se fait
sans alors j'ai posé la question LG ils
ont refusé de me dire quelle technologie
ils ont derrière on va imaginer une
technologie assez proche du wifi pas
tellement parce qu'il faut quand même
faire passer beaucoup de données mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est que si vous
êtes sûr vous allez avoir aucune des
perdition dès lors que vous passez
devant et autour de votre boîtier on
peut imaginer à l'intérieur du
téléviseur plusieurs antennes pour
recevoir le signal et qui n'est pas de
zone d'ombre mais surtout est-ce qu'il
montre ce qu'il vachement intéressant
c'est qu'on peut avoir un signal
jusqu'en 4K 120 images par seconde alors
120 images par seconde c'est pas
nécessairement pour regarder des films
des séries mais plus pour du gaming
imaginez vous branchez votre ps5 sur
votre boîtier zéro connecte à déporté et
bien vous allez pouvoir jouer jusqu'en
4K à 120 images par seconde et c'est là
où la techno y est intéressante si vous
voulez c'est là où elle est salutaire
c'est qu'elle vient apporter des
solutions concrètes à des problématiques
on a tous chez nous les câbles des gueux
qui courent derrière votre télé si vous
voulez avoir un téléviseur accroché au
mur un truc très joli alors je vous
donne une fois de plus il existe
certaines solutions notamment celle de
Samsung avec le voiture qui est génial
mais là l'idée d'avoir un boîtier 100%
sans fil je trouve ça juste absolument
malin ça va dans le bon sens alors vous
allez me dire ça vient rajouter des
ondes à la maison là où plein de
personnes ne veulent pas et les
électrocensiles c'est pas forcément fait
pour eux et pour tous les autres qui
veulent avoir un câble management
parfait je pense ici vous avez vraiment
de quoi vous faire plaisir regardez par
exemple ici c'est vachement marrant
parce que vous avez quatre écrans le
premier le deuxième le troisième le
quatrième il y a absolument aucun câble
à part l'alimentation parce que les
boîtiers sont ici premier boîtier qui
est là deuxième boîtier qui est là
troisième boîtier qui est là et le 4e
boîtier qui est là et ces boîtiers
envoie le signal directement à cette
téléviseur je trouve ça marrant alors il
nous montre un peu la distance une fois
de plus ici mais ils viennent illustré
et LG ils aiment bien quand ça pète sur
leur stand et croyez-moi ici franchement
ça pète
LG présente au CES une télé totalement
transparente enfin totalement pas
réellement regarder je vous montre en
fait le truc est vraiment intéressant
ici c'est que vous avez effectivement
une date transparente pour prévoir à
travers d'ailleurs je peux mettre ma
tronche derrière je suis dans la télé je
fais de la télé mais là où le système
est vachement intéressant c'est que vous
allez avoir qui rangeait juste en bas le
dos le dos c'est un espèce de tissu
tissu totalement OPA qui va venir
remonter et qui vous permettra d'abord
deux gros cas d'usage différents le
premier c'est d'avoir de la transparence
comme ça donc on peut l'imaginer sur un
côté un peu plus professionnel B2B dans
des bureaux vous regardez à travers ou
de la décoration mais pourquoi pas dans
un ange vous mettez les petits poissons
ça c'est rigolo et lorsque vous voulez
venir regarder réellement une
présentation et bien votre écran vient
se relever derrière vous voyez il m'a
mal disparaît et là vous profitez d'une
vraie télé et ça c'est vachement bien la
technologie c'est de la OLED tu es on
connaît la qualité de LG au niveau de
ces dalle OLED mais l'idée vous voyez de
venir mixer comme ça c'est assez marrant
et ce qui est marrant en plus c'est
qu'il vient de recycler un peu une
techno qui soit montré il y a quelques
années il me semble-t-il en 2018 déjà au
CES souvenez vous c'est une dalle c'est
un écran qui venait s'enrouler au lieu
d'avoir le dos qui s'enroulait c'était
votre écran qui descendait complètement
il y avait plus d'écran j'ai dans un
espèce de bac en bas un grand rangement
lorsque vous avez pas besoin de télé et
bien la télé était en bas qu'on vous
aviez besoin de la télé la télé remontée
ici c'est à peu près le même système
sauf que il garde la dalle qui est
totalement transparente et ils viennent
monter et descendre le dos de votre
téléviseur oui tout ça marrant parce que
une fois de plus il y a une recycler un
peu leur techno pour apporter de
nouveaux cas d'usage ça va être
effectivement des cas d'usage Audi plus
pour professionnel le particulier je
suis pas très sûr ou peut-être pour des
multimillionnaires des milliardaires qui
veulent se faire un petit kiffe dans une
maison avec un très grand écran qui
s'enroule qui monte mon wyotte je trouve
ça marrant une fois de plus je suis pas
sûr vous l'ayez un jour chez vous mais
la techno est là LG innove et une fois
de plus ça ça me fait kiffer
vous avez derrière moi des
réfrigérateurs avec les panneaux qui
vont venir changer de couleur je trouve
ça une fois de plus très marrant
innovation ciné LG en fait c'est des
panneaux RGB que vous allez avoir donc
si vous vous dites dans le seul matin
j'ai envie d'avoir un frigo un peu plus
on sait rien moi du genre dans un truc
un petit peu tonique BIM on peut y aller
et puis il soit à droite un peu plus
tamiser on se met un petit bleu on peut
le faire ça c'est marrant on peut venir
totalement personnaliser alors après le
truc c'est que ça a émis quand même de
la lumière donc il faut pas craindre
d'avoir un peu de lumière à la maison je
trouve ça marrant pour venir changer
bien évidemment les couleurs on a en
plus des haut-parleurs Bluetooth donc on
peut en plus se mettre de la musique
avec vous avez votre assistant vocal ça
me fait marrer j'ai une petite
innovation alors très honnêtement je
pense pas que ce soit pour le marché
européen je pense pas qu'on lui retrouve
en France mais une fois de plus LG Celli
on peut le faire donc on va le faire
donc on va le montrer et sur le coup je
dois connaître c'est vrai qu'ils ont
raison
[Musique]
qui fait du côté de chez LG c'est toute
la partie gaming on retrouve des
moniteurs OLED qui remonte jusqu'à 240
images par seconde 240 Hertz alors je
vous avais déjà Montréal il y a quelques
mois lorsqu'on est à Berlin au mois de
septembre elle gère des présenter un
moniteur moniteur qui est intéressant
parce que vous avez deux positions
différentes à moniteur qui va être
totalement plat et qui va pouvoir venir
s'incurber lorsque vous les passez dans
un setup de gaming et bien s'incurber
sur les côtés il vient de montrer de
plus les innovations ce qui savent faire
ils savent jouer sur la modularité ils
savent jouer sur l'incurvé c'est une
lolette qui permet d'avoir ça donc ça
c'est assez rigolo et une fois de plus
ici il y a une montrer les muscles avec
des moniteurs qui sont sur boostés sur
vitamine et alors moi je trouve ça cool
parce que LG maîtrisé sur maîtrise ces
dash sont très très fort là-dedans il y
a également de l'audio mais c'est moi le
sujet aujourd'hui je vais vraiment qu'on
regarde grosse innovation qui sont en
train de proposer du côté des écrans on
le voit avec ce boîtier 0 câble on le
voit également avec une télé qui peut
être totalement transparente ou pas en
fonction des besoins et également la
modularité qui se passe ici du côté du
gaming d'ailleurs si vous prévoyez
d'acheter un moniteur gaming prévoyez
peut-être de regarder du côté de nos
like parce que la techno est vraiment
belle elle est juste hyper canon et en
plus 240 images par seconde c'est juste
canoniser voilà il y a plein délégation
qui est en train de passer donc c'est le
moment où on va vous laisser parce que
regarder ça passe de tous les côtés
c'est la fête on est au CNS et ça c'est
chouette voyez les innovations elles
sont partout et ici au CES Enzo veut
même venir se balader faire du vélo j'ai
un écran ici je choisis l'endroit où je
veux aller bref c'est marrant c'est
sympa on fait du sport ça permet de voir
un peu là où veux nous emmener LG et une
fois de plus ces gros innovations je
vais être bientôt essoufflée donc il va
être temps de raccrocher dites-moi ce
que vous pensez de tout ça en bas dans
les commentaires est-ce que vous
pourriez avoir une de ces innovations à
la maison et est-ce qu'elle vous
intéresse marquez moi tout ça je me
balade j'en chie je vous embrasse et à
bientôt ciao allez go
[Musique]